one of the only positive things is sort
of seeing who's who and getting a lot of
clarity about your own positions we were
talking about that earlier it's like my
anti-war position has never felt I've
never felt more confident with it um but
I also am more confident in who's who
and who you know it's beaten those War
drums it has been absolutely like insane
to me to watch what's been happening and
realize that my positions have not
changed through Ukraine through
everything in 2020 that my beliefs you
know especially anti-war beliefs do not
need to be swayed by either side that
it's a bad idea no matter where it's
coming from you saw Lindsey Graham right
yeah his his latest thing was where he
said that he wants to bomb Iran with
even with no evidence yep that was crazy
that was insane that guy should resign
that dude is evil and there's and you
look at the responses of the people
talking about this and there are people
justifying it and it's like when I when
we started seeing all this stuff it
really did become clear to me how the
Patriot Act got passed so quickly